so
you know when i look in when i look
at my coinbase account yeah it has my
trade activity
and i look at thou like at one point i
would send 100 bitcoins
and thousands and thousands i go through
all the history and it just makes me
sick
because now bitcoin has hit what 63
thousand dollars
yeah i was buying bitcoin when it was 20
bucks and
i bought hundreds of them when it was
315 dollars and it stayed there for a
while
but instead of saving it you know at the
time i i couldn't see
uh into the future i didn't i couldn't
predict that bitcoin was going to be
worth 60 thousand dollars i mean who
could
so i was sending it to pay for the the
research chemicals that got me into
trouble
it's so crazy because if i just held on
to those thousands of bitcoins
i would be a billionaire at least
hundreds of millions of dollars so
it's just it's what was what were you
saying about this the ray array of
equipment you had mining them
oh yeah so my friend brandon and his
brother ben were importing containers
full of
uh these 333 mega megahertz asic asic
um bitcoin miners their little usb chip
sets back in the early days when you
could literally mine
coins a day from you know 10 of these
things and
i ordered hundreds of them and i set
them up on like cooling pads with usb
arrays i'd put like 12 in an array or 10
in an array
and i could i could install usb cards in
the computers where i could have like
20 of them going on any individual
machine so i had like five computers
going with a bunch of these my i had one
metal racks like storage racks
and if you open the room i think i have
a picture if you open the room you see
all these little blue lights blinking
and you look at the screens and you can
see i'm in these mining pools and the
bitcoins just racking up
but what's crazy is these by the time
they would get a shipment of miners
like it started with these these 333
megahertz
miners the it would be become harder
to solve a block to one block one
bitcoin
so the benefit of pulling all of your
resources together is 100 different
people can be working to solve the block
together
and then you get paid faster if you're
working on it by yourself then you have
to wait until you've solved the whole
block to get the coin
so we'd pull our resources into these
these groups
and or these pools and so all of our
computational power
was going to mine the bitcoin to to
so we could get paid faster and it's
just so crazy because as bitcoin become
more and more difficult as more bitcoin
got mined there's only what 21 million
something bitcoins that'll ever be
created right it'll never go beyond that
and that's
that's also why the value keeps
increasing as
the volume increases as the 24 hour
volume as more people
start trading and the supply stays fixed
the value will increase how many
bitcoins was your
machine mining a day anywhere between
five and ten i could mine between five
and
in the early days a month later that
became harder my same computational
power
would would only mine three to four a
month later it would only mine two to
three
a month later it would mine one to two a
month later and this was in a period of
months
i mean it it it was very quick the
window was very quick and you were using
these bitcoins that you were mining
every day to
for what for a lot of things i was
selling them i was exchanging
so right so a lot of times i would send
it to china
to pay for a product that and you didn't
need to create fake ids to send bitcoin
right no i didn't
that simplified things a lot yeah for
sure but
if i just held on to the bitcoin you
know it's
what did you do with all the bitcoin
before you got arrested
what i did with all the bitcoin you
still had a lot of bitcoin when you got
popped right
no so i yeah i did have some bitcoin i
had
uh i didn't have a lot most of my
bitcoin i had sent to china okay um i
had a couple all coins like i had some
dodge coin that's gaining a lot of
popularity you had it back then oh yeah
when was that created
uh 2000 um a long time ago 2011 2012
oh it's been around so um name coin
that's how you get like the dot onions
um i when the ethereum came out
eth i bought a bunch of that litecoin
you know i bought i dabbled with
cryptocurrency a lot
you know i'm going to see a friend in
orlando um
hopefully while i'm here in florida who
i put onto cryptocurrency
and just last year he made over a
million dollars this
this it's just unbelievable ju and
here's the thing you don't need to know
anything about trading
you don't need to know how to read the
charts it helps if you do but you don't
need to
all you need to do is look for the new
currencies that are actually
backed by decentralized daos
decentralized autonomous organizations
backed by technology that is promising
oh by the way how many uh
how many bitcoins did you own at the at
your peak
oh man i mean any figure out how
how what your net worth would be right
now so at any given time like the
problem is
i would have like a hundred here a
hundred there a dozen here
a dozen there a hundred here any and you
know but at any given time i never
watched thousands just so humor me for
one point but in total
yeah probably five thousand bitcoins you
had five thousand bitcoin
at any given time yeah i mean in total
if you total it all up for sure
so what's the math 5 000 times
55 000.
i don't want to hear this number don't
want to hear it
275 million there you go jesus christ
of a billion that's bonkers
you know and i know so many people that
came from nothing and now they're
swimming in cash making good investments
um i know
plenty of people that are literally
crypto millionaires
i i'm going to see one in orlando um
but what does he do so after he got that
after he got the million dollars right
after he
his his initial investment turned into
a million in this certain altcoin right
right it doesn't stop you just keep it
in there or do you pull any out keeps
exchanging one currency for another
so don't sell off everything
take back your initial investment when
it get your initial investment back and
exchange it back for your local native
currency or whatever you choose to be
your long-term store of value
whether that's bitcoin or usd or
whatever
put it in something that that that you
that's accessible that's gonna
that's safe to you leave the rest of it
in the market
and now now when you see that a current
you buy the dips
so when you see that a currency is down
30 percent
read the news about it make sure you're
not making a bad purchase but more often
not it's going to rebound
buy the dip don't buy the peak don't buy
when bitcoins
you know 63 000 and it's at the top of a
peak and you haven't seen it drop in
forever
wait be patient it's going to go back
down
buy it wait for it to increase and and
then you can keep so if you have
if you have say a dozen different
cryptocurrencies you can just
monitor your portfolio they have uh
crypto bubbles so you can look at the
performance on crypto bubbles
and you can see what's down and what's
up and you can make your decisions you
can
you can say okay this is a good time to
exchange this currency for this currency
uh exchange a currency that's up for a
currency that's down
and keep swapping you're not going to
lose and that would be more like a day
trading approach like you're constantly
trying to make trades to make money
and it works as well or you can just
your strategy can literally be
i don't want to learn how to read the
charts i don't want to learn how to
to study and to make calculated
decisions
i just want to buy new currencies and i
want to wait and i want to make money
and that's working for a lot of people
it's working for a lot of people you
don't have to be a smart trader
or and you just don't so it's it's wild
man
interesting times yeah for real
i